well in a couple of days time it's the
Chinese New Year and we thought we could
mark the Chinese New Year by looking at
a bit of the chemistry of tea so before
we start have to make some tea I will
just go along the corridor to the start
and Robin so we're going to make some
green tea and some ordinary tea as well
so we can compare them I don't really
like black tea very much but I'm very
fond of green tea and they're the same
plant but they're just processed
differently and we put some in my teacup
as well
I just personal uses it yet that should
just keeping me going
chemists never trust clinking out of
beakers so we give each of them a stir
and then go back to my office it's the
green tea it's the ordinary tea I want
to try and show you what happens when
you put lemon in tea so if I cut the
lemon in half and you know lemon juice
is very acid so let's see what happens I
will move the two together so all being
well we can compare them so are you
ready
we will try squeezing in some lemon
juice
so apart from the pit going can you see
that as we have added the lemon juice is
gone really much lighter color and the
reason for this is that tea contains
molecules or chemicals that behave like
circle indicators they change color when
you put acids in and what happens is
that the acid from the lemon juice adds
a proton to the molecule of the
indicator in here the one that changes
color and just by adding this proton it
causes the bonds in the molecule to
switch around and so they absorb light
in quite a different way now tea isn't
doesn't give you a terribly dramatic
color change compared to some of the
indicators that like litmus that people
have used in the lab which can go from
pink to blue but it doesn't do badly
there's quite a lot of argument whether
chemically it makes any difference if
you put the milk into the cap before the
tea or you fill up the tea with the cup
with tea and then add the milk
afterwards and there's some people who
get really passionate they will only
drink tea with the milk before all the
milk afterwards and they swear that
there are big differences do you have a
position on this I don't have any
position at all I don't like milking
teas so I don't enter into that debate
at all the different sorts of teas that
you buy are basically the same plant but
they differ from the different
components that there are in the tea the
when you put tea in water the water the
hot water extracts a huge number of
different chemicals from the tea these
are not pesticides and things that have
been added but their actual chemicals
that are created by the plant when they
grow and depending where the plant grows
whether it has been a sunny summer
whether it's been a wet summer so that
the different amounts of the chemicals
changes
so one of my colleagues who works here
used to work for a company that sold tea
and they wanted to analyze it to find
out how the different sorts of tea
varied so they used a machine like the
one behind me which is called a nuclear
magnetic resonance spectrometer NMR
spectrometer which measures the
different sorts of hydrogen atoms in a
particular molecule now the problem with
tea is it's quite easy to get a sample
of tea and put it in a tube like this
but this then goes inside that machine
you can see a whole series of them
waiting to go in there those are not tea
but there are chemicals from the
department but what you end up with is a
really complicated picture of all the
thousands of different components of tea
and here I've got a real spectrum of
green tea and you can see it looks a
complete mess lots and lots and lots of
components along here but the important
thing is and what they were trying to do
in their analysis was to see how the
different sorts of teas varied and see
if they could see a real difference
between something that tasted nice and
something that wasn't quite as good and
although you can't necessarily identify
their individual compounds you can say
that some say here are due to different
sorts of sugars and these are due to
more complicated molecules the so so
called polyphenols but even the chemists
like me doesn't really know what all
these compounds are though you can get
an idea how one differs compared to
another
part of the reason why people like the
red dark tea rather than green tea is
the dark tea has a lot more caffeine in
it than the green tea the processing of
the tea concentrates the caffeine and
probably the fermentation actually
generates more of it now the caffeine
doesn't have very much effect on the
taste of the tea or of coffee and so
some people find if they drink too much
coffee or tea late at night they can't
go to sleep and so nowadays it's quite
fashionable to have decaffeinated tea or
coffee the problem is that the
traditional way of removing clean from
coffee or tea is using dry cleaning
fluid dry cleaning fluid is a carbon
compound of carbon chlorine and hydrogen
which sometimes can leave quite
unpleasant residues in the coffee beans
or the tea leaves and so nowadays the
preferred method for removing caffeine
from tea and coffee is by using highly
compressed carbon dioxide so called
supercritical carbon dioxide which can
dissolve out the caffeine without
dissolving very much else from the
material and co2 is completely harmless
in terms of health people drink tea
drink water with co2 in it every day and
so it doesn't leave any residues at all
and the process is rather better with
coffee because with coffee it just
removes the caffeine with tea it does
review remove some of the flavor
components and they have to be put back
in again afterwards and the caffeine
that you extract can be sold on to
people who make caffeinated drinks the
ones that give you energy and keep you
awake and so this is a good process
because you put calm dioxide of your tea
or coffee and make a more valuable
decaffeinated product
you have some caffeine to sell to
somebody else
Noreen had naturopathy she gensphoto
Sadashiv in satsang Julian Union that
eventually